what a do yo your boy dog sleeps his
back and a day weekend spicy with dune
by Frank Herbert hi let me explain
something real quick like 20 thousand
years in the future humanity done spread
- with other planets run by hood rich
crews called houses who all taking their
orders from the Emperor this whole space
hood run off a dank herb called Milan's
spice on the streets see the only place
you can score spices up on a planet of a
raucous wit ain't nothing but a bunch of
sand worm riding thugs
called Freeman these cats just sitting
on the asses waiting for a legendary
Savior Carla's on our guy he we're gonna
turn a raucous until a water filled
paradise now there also be a clique of
fine biddies called
Benny jezereth you strapped with some
bangin superpowers where it is they
trying to breed the first ever male
super dude called the quiz lights hotter
rock whose power is gonna be the slow
lesseps whoa so one day the Emperor tell
Duke Leto of House Atreides that he
nailed top dog of spice mining on a
raucous right before they bounced over
to the planet The Dukes Benny G Jessica
puts their son Paul to an old-school
test and truth is Paul got a mind way
beyond your day bud things ain't quite
what they were expected on a rocket
turns out the Emperor playing dirty and
what he really plotted is the ways all
the players of House Atreides but
instead of coming out and saying it to
that face
the emperor puts his muscle behind the
homies our house our cannon who Ben
people with their treaties for years the
arcanist gotta ace in the hole doe
dukale's boy doc you'ii
fools actually a snitch who drops the
Duke right into Baron Harkonnen slap the
duke trying to take the bearing down
with them but ends up just icing himself
and some other de broglie's feelin like
a real [ __ ] you he helps parla Jessica
bus ass out of there when they join up
with the Fremen on the outside years
pass and Paul now known on the streets
as Paul or deed says Paul been chewing
that spice all day every day
powers been getting turnt along with
pause balls fighting skills and clutch
leadership the Fremen start thinking he
the legendary prophet so limp DZ rallies
up is Freeman Posse to stop them
Harkonnen scrubs but before they roll
out Paul decided gonna step up his game
so he takes a long pull from the water
of life when he wakes up from a
nasty-ass drank nap his powers so damn
ballin that he can see past present and
future like it ain't no thing using that
side he find out that the emperor then
assembled a big-ass army that he's gonna
use to put the hurt on Paul so Paul
enough lemon hop up on the sandworms and
wreck earning fool they step two then
the Emperor try to throw down but Paul
are like a tread is nuts son snatches
the throne like a boss and because the
new emperor thing is since you can see
the future
he realized he ain't gonna be able to
stop the bleed gasp holy war I had some
brothers doing all about the planet of
rockets and ecology how any little hook
and transformer planet and it turns be
transformed by but for this dog right
here talk about my man Paul Atreides is
where is that first off the name of
[ __ ] comes from that play Agamemnon
from Greek myth cuz like a memnon even
though Paul come from a family that got
solid street cred and fat stacks his
future full of tragedy see the thing I
dig about Paul is that even though he
packaged some sick powers he know he
ain't all that
check it more deed could indeed see the
future but you must understand the
limits of this power think of sight
you have eyes yet cannot see with our
life just so mu indeed cannot always
choose to look across the mysterious
terrain but that don't stop people from
riding this junk 24/7 even on the Fremen
thing Paul the play of legend they don't
know the truth like he do eventually
Paul realizes the universe ain't just
the big unknown
it's the infinite I know and Paul pity
the fool who thing he or anyone else
can't control everything so I've liked
the Fremen you bet in all your chips on
a savior who can't do no wrong
you straight horrific cuz they nobody
that contained infinite not huh
even Paul with this I can see the past
present and future bullets can't do
nothing to stop the world from the mess
that lay ahead and Paul saw how futile
were any efforts of this to change any
smallest bit of this he had thought to
oppose the jihad within himself but the
jihad would be his leaders would rage
out from a rockets even without him they
needed only the legend he already had
become but peeps gonna do what they do
worship a savior who they thinking gonna
solve all their problems even Paul's
realist home he's gonna jump at the
chance to lay their free will at that
players feet and that instant Paul saw
how still gar had been transformed from
the Fremen naive to a creature of the
listen our God a receptacle for all and
obedience it was a lessening of the man
and Paul felt the ghost wind of the
jihad ended on the real in a in a savior
we should be looking for to fix our
lives we got to use these righteous
players as an inspiration nut up and
make that change ourselves but ain't
nothing in your life gonna be fixed to
you hit that subscribe button
catch you later peace
[Music]